اكيد
لا بينما حوصرت هذه العائلات داخل غرفتين
صغيرتين باحد المنازل في مدينه حلب يقول
هؤلاء ان الاطفال هنا لا يستطيعون تحمل
الجوع والضغوط النفسيه
للحرب بدنا خبز كهرباء ومي كل 16 خبزه ب
50 ورقه اليوم بعثته لاخوي من الصبح من
الساعه 6 لهلا ماجيب خبز وهلا الساعه
الساعه 3ه لهلا ماو جايب خبز وفي ظل
انقطاع متواصل للتيار الكهربائي والمياه
على مدى اسابيع طويله يتزايد شعور الياس
بين الناس هنا بالنسبه لي انا الله سبحانه
وتعالى جعلني جعلها الاولاد اخشي اربيه
اعيشن هدول مسؤولين مني ونظرا للنقص الحاد
في مخزون الدقيق وصلت اسعار الخبز الى
مستويات قياسيه بينما قفز سعر جالون النفط
من 85
ليره خلال عه ايام فقط ويبدو ان وراء
الصراع البقاء الذي يخوضه السكان هنا خوف
دائم وانعدام شبه تام للامن فالقناه
منتشرون في كل مكان بينما تتعرض احياء
المدينه لقصف مدفعي وجوي بين الحين والاخر
وفي مدينه لطالما اشتهرت بجمالها وتراثها
العريقين اصبحت شوارعها مكبا للنفايات
التي تهدد الصحه العامه ومع تفاقم الماساه
في حلب لا يبدو ان احدا من السكان هنا يرى
اي بصيص امل لحل قد يلوح بالافق
القريب